winter is coming very very slowly season
3 episode 2 dark wings dark words and
not a lot more is going on this time
around them there was in the last
episode I'm probably gonna have to give
this one a pass because the last episode
didn't have enough time to touch on all
the different stories that were going on
and the bulk of this one is taken up
with the stories that weren't addressed
in the last one that said that's not too
heh pisode zat a road that not a lot
actually happens things better pick up
next episode cuz otherwise if this is
the pace for the whole season I'm gonna
start to take issue with that eventually
you just gotta start moving this thing
forward that's not to say that it's not
moving forward at all but it's kind of
inching forward which maybe it wouldn't
bother me so much except that there's
all this talk about the open rebellion
of so many kingdoms and the the Knights
watches is on the run from the White
Walkers and the wildlings are gathering
but everybody's just kind of moving
around nobody's fighting nobody's even
skirmishing and I know part of its
budgetary i mean the the show up to this
point has been really really good at
giving you the feel that battles are
going on without actually showing you
too many because they're really
expensive to shoot but at least in
previous seasons you got that feel that
this stuff was still going on but at
least this episode spend some time with
some of my favorite characters first
we've got Arya Stark and I just love her
I love the whole basis of her character
I like the guys that they've paired her
with this sort of odd little offbeat
trio and I'm gonna be really interested
to see what happens with her I feel like
she's got the most potential to go in
any number of different directions we
also get to spend a bit more time with
bran who is becoming more and more
interesting to me as time goes on and
also like Aria it seems like there's a
quite a few ways he could go and there's
a little bit more sense of mystery in
some ways with a lot of these characters
it feels like they've only got maybe two
or three things that could happen to the
brand Aria I could see a lot of
different ways these two could play out
and that's part of what's really
interesting about them highlight though
has got to be Jaime Lannister and
Brienne of Tarth first of all these two
together
fantastic antagonistic chemistry they're
just great together and it's not just
the returning people that were getting
good stuff from we've got now the
introduction of the legendary diana rigg
now she's really interesting she's
getting into Sansa's good sighting
getting her to open up a little bit
about Joffrey I'll come back to Sansa in
a minute but it's she's got this thing
where she's pulling the information I
never be like I don't know if we can
trust this lady but she's really
interesting and she's fun to watch now
speaking of Sansa I'm kind of done with
her as a character I think what's
driving me crazy about sands is that it
feels like she hasn't learned or grown
at all in her time just the fact that
she opens up to Diana Riggs character as
soon as she first meets you I mean I
understand she wants somebody to talk to
but it's just like you just don't learn
do you and maybe part of the problem is
that you I can tell she's visually aging
cuz the show itself is a little bit
vague in terms of the time frame of how
much time is passing with all of this
but to see her visibly getting older but
not really seeming to mature is a little
bit annoying especially considering that
bran and Arya are noticeably maturing
even Robb Stark and some of the other
ones they're growing and maturing and
she seems kind of stuck I'm complaining
a lot again it was not a bad episode it
was a good episode and I'm hoping that
once I had the scope of the whole season
all of this stuff this I don't want to
call it boring but the slower paced
stuff in the first two episodes will pay
off very well but right now i'm waiting
for the season to get a kick in the ass
I've talked about some of my favorite
characters in the show who are some of
your favorite characters and can even be
ones who have been killed off already
drop it down in the comments let's talk
about it and until next time council is
adjourned